leute zockt mehr computerspiele das ist
das resümee unseres heutigen videos
immer mal wieder heißt es ja dass
computerspiele dumm machen
aber jetzt gibt es den endgültigen
gegenbeweis und zwar direkt aus der
wissenschaft ein experiment hat nämlich
gezeigt dass man durch regelmäßiges
computerspielen vorteile beim lernen hat
und das zeigt sich auch im gehirn jedes
experiment genau ablief und warum diese
ergebnisse auch für die ältere
generation durchaus spannend sein
könnten
jetzt sind links und science und fiction
herzlich willkommen
ja schon früher man haben ja
untersuchungen gezeigt computerspiele
können positive effekte haben die
reaktionszeit kann durch regelmäßiges
joggen verkürzt werden und zudem können
gamer durch das spielen ihr
arbeitsgedächtnis stärken ein
forschungsteam aus sind bochum hat uns
jetzt einen weiteren grund geliefert
weiterhin regelmäßig zeit mit der
spielekonsole zu verbringen
die 34 probanden die iris experiment
unterteilt sich in zwei gruppen 17 von
ihnen hatten angegeben würden sich mehr
als 15 stunden video spiele zu zocken
die anderen 17 teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer machten sie das dagegen eher
selten
in dem experiment aus bochum hatten die
probanden die aufgabe den sogenannten
wettervorhersage presse zu machen
dabei handelt es sich um einen
etablierten test der das lernen von
wahrscheinlichkeiten abfahren dabei
werden kombinationen aus drei spielen
karten angezeigt wobei sie mit
unterschiedlichen wahrscheinlichkeit für
regen und sonnenschein verknüpft sind
die probanden kennen die erstmal nicht
sie schätzen die wahrscheinlichkeit der
symbol kombinationen ein und bekommen
dann die antwort ob ihre einschätzung
eben korrekt war oder nicht mit der zeit
werden sie durch dieses feedback also in
die lage versetzt zu verstehen welche
kombinationen was bedeuten sie lernen
also welche karten kombination für
welche wettervorhersage stehen
am ende des experiments füllten alle
probanden dann noch einen fahrer bog aus
in dem das wissen über die spielkarten
und ihre bedeutung zusätzlich noch
einmal abgefragt wurde und ihr könnt es
euch sicher denken die gamer waren
signifikant besser waren die spielkarten
korrekt mit den wahrscheinlichkeiten zu
verknüpfen deutlich besser als die
kontrollgruppe schnitten sie vor allem
beispiel kombination mit hoher
unsicherheit ab also wenn die
kombination der spielkarten zu 60% sonne
und zu 40% regen vorher sagte zum
beispiel auch das ergebnis der frage
würden überzeugte das forschungsteam von
dem guten abschneiden der gamer im
vergleich zur kontrollgruppe
denn hier wurde deutlich dass diejenigen
die häufig zocken die bedeutung der
karten besser durchschauen als die an
und sabrina schenk eine der beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen sagt dazu unsere
studie zeigt dass videospieler besser
planen sind situationen schnell zu
erfassen neues wissen zu generieren und
wissen zu kategorisieren ja und für
dieses ergebnis sieht man sie auch
gleich eine erklärung mit ihrer ansicht
nach simulieren computerspiele bestimmte
hirnregion zocken ist also training für
das gehirn das liegt auch eine
magnetresonanztomographie nadi gemacht
wurde im rahmen dieses experiments im
gehirn der gamer war der hippocampus
während des lernprozesses deutlich
aktiver als bei der kontrollgruppe
und genau diese hirnregion spielt eine
entscheidende rolle beim lernen und für
gedächtnisleistung und
dieses ergebnis ist nicht nur für die
gamer unter und seine super nachricht
auch ältere generationen könnten von den
positiven effekten des videospiels
profitieren denn im hippocampus finden
im alltag veränderungen statt die
leistung des gedächtnisses nimmt ab das
könnte wiederum mit videospielen
therapiert werden ja wie immer als ich
euch zu diesem thema und zu allen
anderen auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
video verpassen wollt dann dort wer hier
ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke ja
hier geht es weiter mit gaming ist
gesund das ist nämlich auch noch
spannendes video ansonsten bis dann
bleibt